noch ein kurzer ausblick sollte le pen
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
der fahnenstange ist noch nicht erreicht
an einem tag der geprägt war von der
es gibt noch klärungsbedarf zwischen der
türkische armee kurdische kämpfer im
also es gibt eine kleine lebensweisheit
auch um die sanktionen umgehung der
ist eine katastrophe ich finde keine
hat die bundeswehr und sie kann so lässt
ihren särgen
her dass händisch welt so und wisla
in amerikas hauptstadt will die
in den sternen andrea maurer über eine
das rennen machen kommen ja auf europa
vielen dank valerie nach frankfurt die
heißt es heute abend in frankreich
nordirak aus der luft und am boden in
zeitenwende in der wir stehen die
parteichefin wurden was folgt nennt
von walter jens die ich erinnere auf dem
worte ich weiß nicht weiter das hier ist
ukraine und deutschland aber es gibt
us-sanktionen das war das ziel aller
gause und bettina schausten guten abend
sie wissen keine abgeben weil ein
wirklich veränderte harte zeiten zu sie
partei am abgrund
internationale finanz elite lösungen
präsident gegen herausforderin mitte
weg zum abgrund hat er gesagt kann eine
hennig welt so die schwierigste phase in
ukraine stemmt sich gegen den aufmarsch
neuauflage der staatlichen förderung für
doch mein ganzes leben
seit februar 21 war sie zusammen mit
parteien im landtag das war auch weit
damit sich die ukraine gegen die
nirgendwo zweifel dass die ukraine lebt
drittel nicht einsatzbereit ist und der
finden auf die zahlreichen probleme
der geschichte unserer partei
shanghai wurde der strikte corona
panne lebensrettend sein wir sagen
das hoch hier über skandinavien und die
gegen rechts europa freund gegen
russischer truppen im osten was dafür an
definiert ja auch das verhältnis zu
verbreitete stimmung im land doch war
dieser zeit pandemie krieg inflation
energieeffizientes bauen ist nach
russischen angreifer zur wehr setzen
richtungsstreit wahl-debakel jetzt mit
rest nicht entbehrlich wir brauchen auch
und dass sie weiterleben muss
janine wissler parteichefin der linken
schwere gefechte gibt es seit gestern
russland deutlich anders wann sie eine
tiefs renate simone und talke für uns
parteien haben ja gerne mal ein längeres
lockdown für weitere vier millionen
waffen nötig ist darüber geht hier bei
kann haben mehrere nato länder jetzt
diese stiftung der richtige weg schwesig
wenigen stunden wieder gestoppt worden
nationalistin fünf tage vor der
vorwürfe partei und fraktion sind von
heute um 13.30 schmeißt susanne hennig
klimawandel all das führt zu düsteren
auch in anderen städten zum beispiel in
atmosphäre hier
leben als es in den zeiten großer krisen
menschen gelockert ende märz hatten die
die mader als hauptwaffensysteme der
uns die diskussion weiter genauso wie
prognose wie es ausgeht sonntag
weitere waffenlieferungen angekündigt
das zusätzlich bereitgestellte geld eine
stichwahl um die präsidentschaft liefern
interessant ist jetzt erstmal noch das
bei ihrem besuch im baltikum kritisierte
hat sie mittlerweile als fehler
ihrem rücktritt dennoch überrumpelt ja
bundeswehr um unsere landes und
prognosen so rechnet der iwf für
welt so hin sie nennt persönliche gründe
kandidaten und er wird bis zum schluss
marion
erscheint aber die lage der linkspartei
behörden alle 26 millionen einwohner
bezeichnet nord stream 2 ebenso der
tief renate das bringt nämlich bald mit
teils auch von schwerem gerät die usa
die aufarbeitung was im verhältnis zu
milliarde euro ist laut
kraske und kriminal und
sich emanuel makro und marine le pen das
also in dem umfang licht materie frauen
wir haben eine zugespitzte situation ich
bündnisverteidigung unsere
ist schon sehr nahe am abgrund in ihrer
die deutsche außenministerin
aber auch die jüngsten sexismus vorwürfe
machen
weltweit nur noch mit 3,6 prozent
und kühle luft aber zum ende der woche
bündnisverpflichtungen sowohl in den
opposition reicht das nicht wie ist es
angewiesen zu hause zu bleiben
russland in den letzten jahren schief
bundeswirtschaftsministerium bereits
großbritannien die niederlande
ausdrücklich das festhalten der früheren
einstigen hochburg
weiß dass der parteivorstand heute abend
und die umfragen entwickeln sich derzeit
vor fünf jahren gab es ja das gleiche
einzige fernsehduell das rennen ist eng
in der partei der umgang mit sexismus in
wie jeden tag veröffentlicht das
deutschland wird selbst keine schweren
wird immer mehr tief simone spannend für
wirtschaftswachstum 0,8 weniger als bei
ausgeschöpft die zuständige kfw bat
zu dieser klima stiftungsgründung die ja
einsätzen vor ort an der ostflanke der
noch immer ist rund die hälfte davon
lief verantwortung wird neu definiert
saarland kam sie ja noch auf 2,6 prozent
für ihn man merkt doch im land viele
regierung am bau der deutsch russischen
tagt um schlussfolgerungen aus der
duell thoma ist das dann mal für sich
nato als auch in der dahinter stehenden
russische verteidigungsministerium auch
uns denn das bringt von südwesten eher
den eigenen reihen hat eklatante
der vorherigen prognose die deutsche
waffen liefern stemmt sich aber nicht
betroffen viele kommen nicht an
und es steht viel auf dem spiel das
gaspipeline nord stream 2 das war kritik
keine klimastiftung ist gekommen
darum keine anträge mehr zu stellen
ausbildung ausrüstung und logistik
organisationen haben dazu aufgerufen die
defizite unserer partei offen gelegt ich
heute auch bei der linken deren
gesamtsituation auch den mito vorwürfen
entschied ziemlich klar sogar wird der
heute bilder vom kriegsgeschehen und
bei der bundestagswahl scheiterte sie an
wechselhaftes wetter heute nacht ist es
dagegen ein regierungssprecher machte
wirtschaft soll nur noch um 2,1 prozent
lebensmittel und medikamente laut
schon im januar musste die staatliche
offensichtlich das zeigen jetzt die
wahrzunehmen ist deutschland zu
vorsitzende hinwarf über all das bringen
duell läuft seit 21 uhr und thomas walde
rechtsakte kandidatin extremen rechten
lässt die welt wissen man habe
der fünf prozent hürde kommen dann nur
an angela merkel aber ließ aufhorchen
ausgang dieses duells heute eigentlich
entschuldige mich bei den betroffenen
zu ziehen aber dass susanne henning welt
meist stark bewölkt hier in der
nochmals deutlich man sei eingebunden in
förderung für nachhaltiges bauen abrupt
ersten details gab es keine
behörden sind in shanghai nur 17
wachsen eine korrektur um minus 1,7
dank dreier direktmandate wieder in den
und unterstütze alle anstrengungen die
zögerlich gibt das größte land der eu
1053 militärobjekte in der ukraine
zu verhindern gewerkschaft in künstler
die wahl mit entscheiden oder wie stark
nordhälfte und das kann richtung sachsen
fahrlässigkeit bei der
denn es ist auch kritik an der früheren
wir sie jetzt auf den neuesten stand und
sodann heute diesen schritt gegangen ist
menschen an dem virus verstorben eine
beobachtet es für uns nicht allein
die international abgestimmten
bundestag die parteiinternen querelen
eingestellt werden die mittel waren
entstehungsgeschichte der stiftung das
prozentpunkte
jetzt nötig sind um aus der linken eine
und andere es gibt schon zu einem
auch noch ein bisschen regnen im süden
mit entscheiden
erfolgreich angegriffen überprüft war
war für mich eine überraschung melanie w
was es kann in riga trifft
beginnen in mario pohl wo einem
energiepolitik des regierungspartners
sondern in einer kneipe am pariser gare
lieferungen dass deutschland seinen
ausgeschöpft im kommenden jahr soll es
der ungelöste richtungsstreit der
zahl die international angezweifelt wird
ist alles sehr mit der heißen nadel
kleinen schub in seine richtung so dass
partei zu machen in der sexismus keinen
ist es dagegen klar und so sinken die
erst die pandemie jetzt der krieg wir
also es gibt dort umfrage tatsächlich
spd die tut sich nicht leicht mit der
sind diese angaben nicht
gestrickt und da gibt es auch rechtlich
aussenministerin berbalk am nachmittag
regimes landesvorsitzender in rheinland
anteil leisten werde versicherte auch
temperaturen dort bis minus 1 grad am
brutale ukraine kriegt er ja auf eine
du nord thomas nach gut einer stunde
kommandeur der ukrainischen verteidiger
ein neues programm geben
man davon ausgehen könnte dass er das
platz hat unter dem hashtag linke me to
steuerrecht ich sehr viele fragen die
in der korona pandemie hat sich der
die außenministerin annalena baerbock
noch sehr viele wählerinnen und wähler
pfalz und mitglied im bundesvorstand
die kollegen aus den baltischen staaten
werden von einem sturm heimgesucht bevor
alpenrand milder bleibt es zum beispiel
knapp gewinnt aber gemessen an dem was
und so zeigt sich vladimir putin auch
der horror des krieges ins gesicht
offen sind wenn noch weitere
aufarbeitung ihrer verantwortung bei
fordert nach hennig wels rücktritt
die im ersten wahlgang links gestimmt
traditionell russland freundliche partei
sammeln sich seit tagen wut und vorwürfe
kritik wird nicht laut gemessen am
heute auf ihrer reise ins baltikum
wie schlagen sich die beiden zeichnet
fehlen noch die gewinnzahlen vom lotto
antisemitismus in deutschland verstärkt
in der lausitz mit 6 grad die
wir uns von dem vor regen sturm erholen
da auf dem spiel steht für europa das
geschrieben steht ulrike rolle berichtet
diesem einstigen prestige projekt unter
sich ein sieger ab gab es schon
trifft die eigentlich ja die auflösung
weitere konsequenzen meines erachtens
entsprechend optimistisch bei einer
zutage treten die vielleicht noch mehr
haben noch nicht wissen wir werden sie
sexismus sexueller missbrauch
am mittwoch sie lauten ohne gewähr 10 16
dennoch hält die diskussion um deutsche
bruttoinlandsprodukt leistet estland mit
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
konnten das resultat ist ein massiver
das bundesamt für verfassungsschutz
sich im zweiten wahlgang in der
auffälligkeiten besonderheit
veranstaltung mit russischen bürgern
der nato fordert also es scheint dass
nach muss die ganze partei da
druck steht vor allem die spd
deutsch französische verhältnis und
verstrickungen vor allen dingen wie
zwischen 10 grad zum beispiel hier in
machtmissbrauch mehr als 60 personen
stichwahl entscheiden sollen weil sie
waffenlieferungen an andreas kienast
die lage sei grauenvoll sagt der
abstand die gewaltigste hilfe dann kommt
berichtet durch die pandemie seien
die partei selbst nicht mehr weiß wofür
einbruch der weltwirtschaft
ehrenamtlichen sie trägt den namen
ähnliches le pen hat deutschland sehr
thüringen und 20 grad am oberrhein und
konsequenzen treffen das heißt wir
19 20 35 44 superzahl 3 weitere
ministerpräsidentin von mecklenburg
fragwürdige verstärkungen zu tage
sowohl den makro und auf mittel penn
sollen sich inzwischen beim linken
also es gab es sagen zwei themen die
jahrhundertealte
heftig kritisiert in diesem wahlkampf
sie eigentlich stehen soll und die
verantwortlich dafür sind hauptsächlich
stellvertretende bürgermeister von mario
litauen dann deutschland dann lettland
russland das land der möglichkeiten die
vorpommern die die gaspipeline vehement
die ukraine tanzt sie lebt und sie will
fördern dann wäre glaube ich ein thema
verschwörungsvorstellungen neu
müssen das debattieren wir müssen
eigentlich wenig anfangen können und
morgen ist das wetter ganz
missbrauchsvorwürfe einer ja eigentlich
jugendverband gemeldet haben der will
ist das doch zu knapp und ist er aus ich
die russische invasion der ukraine und
hauptsächlich besprochen wurden und das
unterschiedlich wir haben zum teil
pohl über seine stadt die meisten
beim letzten mal vor fünf jahren
verbreitet worden und reichten bis in
ehrlich zueinander sein und meiner
verteidigt hatte heute äußerte sich
strahlenden sonnenschein zum beispiel in
nun nicht länger schweigen weil es
so genannte russische militär operation
sind auch die themen die im wahlkampf
am leben bleiben im friedrichstadtpalast
wir müssten eigentlich die gesamten
es wird immer die frage geben ob man
sich feministisch verstehen partei die
die schockwellen die das rund um den
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
doch zu schwach und sich da schon
gebäude zerstört ein leben dort fast
enttäuscht waren dann doch am ende firma
sehr häufig gesprochen wurden das erste
meinung nach müsste der ganze partei
schleswig-holstein oder auch zwischen
die mitte der gesellschaft
manuela schwesig gegenüber dem zdf zu
verspricht putin dann auch wird zu einem
beruhigt zurückzulehnen
deutschen zwischen geschäfte der letzten
erstens langsam offen wird dass es ein
bitten am abend politiker tänzer
globus verursacht
kommen hier noch oben drauf also ich
core gestimmt zu haben und der immer
nicht noch mehr machen kann und
der mosel und dem alpenrand hier im
nicht mehr möglich
thema war kauf kamen es ging darum wer
vorstand neu gewählt werden auch janine
guten ende kommen
jahre von schröder über sigmar gabriel
dankeschön thomas walde nach paris so
text
in diesem stahlwerk soll noch etwa 2500
den vorwürfen bernd mosebach aus
netz ist dass es bundesweit es melden
glaube es wird mehr brauchen als nur
mehr nach rechts gerückt weil sie mit
künstler einmal mehr um hilfe damit ihr
nordosten dagegen bleibt es trüb das
natürlich müssen alle regierungen noch
ja damit sind wir am ende aber das
neue gesichter die analyse von theo koll
die gab es von anfang an gesagt das ziel
dessen politik nicht einverstanden sind
sei eine schande wie viel
selten bekam die turnusmäßige
steinmeier merkel altmaier aller waren
will was unternehmen damit die menschen
schwerin
wissler wird es schwer haben sich an der
sich aus dem ganzen bundesgebiet leute
kann auch ein bisschen tröpfeln da haben
mehr versuchen
irgendwo hinterm horizont auf dem grund
land ihre kultur nicht verstummt
nun noch einmal nachrichten die mit den
da können also solche diskussionen wie
menschenverachtung auch heute verbreitet
auslandsjournal beginnt und das sollten
parteispitze zu halten seit drei stunden
ukrainische soldaten seien sie wollen
bei uns bei der linksjugend
frühjahrstagung von iwf und weltbank so
in frankreich besser mit der inflation
vielen dank nach berlin
sie mit etwas glück vielleicht drei oder
dieser operation ist unseren leuten zu
wirtschaftlichen folgen des kriegs
in wollten hier und da ist das nur die
würde jüdinnen und juden in deutschland
sie nicht verpassen antje pieper war in
brett der parteivorstand in einer
klarkommen das war im grunde ein
der ostsee liegt sie die pipeline im
nicht aufgeben heute nun meldet sich von
und in den nachrichten kern wir noch
viel beachtung selten waren die probleme
heute abend diese einzige tv satelliten
gleichzeitig haben wir aber auch von
vier sonnenstunden ganz anders sieht es
beginn das thema bei der frühjahrstagung
möchte ich sagen das ist auch für uns
spitze des eisbergs politisch ist die
helfen im don was ein normales und
finanzpolitisches ein austausch
digitalen sondersitzung den linken droht
polen und hat dort ukrainische
versprach sie schutz
hafen von mukran auf rügen liegt ein
kann da bei diesen wählerin und wieder
einmal zurück in die ukraine gundula
dort ein ukrainischer kommandeur zu wort
die es zu bewältigen gibt vergleichbar
des internationalen währungsfonds gundel
besseres leben zu leben
flüchtlinge getroffen unbedingt dran
hier richtung süden aus da gibt es das
ein führungskampf
finanzpolitischer details der schwer 40
stiftung bereits tot ihr ende wollen
anderen leuten vorher schon sehr sehr
gause
versorgungsschiff dass bei der
mutmaßlich ein sogenannter reichs bürger
seine botschaft verzweifelt
vielleicht etwas bewirken und das kann
groß
wir werden das konsequent zu ende führen
heute nahmen auch die finanzminister der
bleiben und
kein tabu aber so sehr sich deutschland
ja und da fragen wir nach bei theo koll
vollendung von nord stream zwei gute
viele informationen bekommen und waren
wie zum beispiel die weltweit hohe
astronomische mögliche 14 sonnenstunden
jetzt alle parteien vor einem jahr
eu-ratspräsident michelle war
hat im baden-württembergischen boxberg
da die umfragen doch recht knapp sind
um 0.30 ist hier wieder zeit für unser
aber nachzuvollziehen war wird am ende
das ist unser appell an die welt es kann
am mittag waren die limousinen des
dienste geleistet hat die bluechip
standen noch spd cdu und linke hinter
g20 staaten an den beratungen von iwf
in berlin wir hören der parteivorstand
überraschend zu gesprächen mit präsident
inflation und eben zunehmende probleme
zum beispiel an der donau an der isar
mehr macht lebendiger wurde ist
einen polizeibeamten angeschossen und
bemüht es hakt zwischen berlin und kiew
dann ungläubig wollten das
insgesamt noch einen ausschlag gaben
heute-journal update mit nacktem ihr
aber auch an der kieler bucht oder in
mutmaßlich gekauft und betrieben von der
sie lenski in kiew dabei kündigte
ukrainischen botschafter ins willy
innerparteilich klären am karfreitag
hat heute abend getagt oder ist immer
tatsächlich in der letzten viertelstunde
ihr wenn jetzt einige sich nicht mehr
der letzte unseres lebens sein wir haben
und weltbank teil finanzminister lindner
leicht verletzt bei einem sek-einsatz
auch für die entwicklungsländer valerie
es hakt gewaltig dass die ukraine um
als viel über internationale politik
muss bis morgen guten abend spiel heißt
noch dabei was hören sie welche
brandt haus gerollt aussprache zwischen
macht der spiegel fälle aus dem
stiftung klima und umweltschutz
der lübecker bucht am freitag ziehen
mitchell an die eu werde der ukraine
in kiew tragen sie heute ihre liebsten
haller ja weil deren volkswirtschaften
wahrscheinlich nur noch wenige tage wenn
daran erinnern dass sie das selber
konsequenzen zieht die partei jetzt in
machte dabei russland allein
sollte das haus des mutmaßlichen täters
geredet wurde das kann man auch so
landesverband hessen öffentlich mehr als
dem entschiedensten antreiber der
macht er bittet ist seit wochen
mitgestimmt haben oder dass sie darüber
verantwortlich für die gegenwärtigen
einige dichtere wolkenfelder noch über
nicht stunden zum überleben der feind
mutmaßlich denn die stiftung zeichnete
nun die gerade erwähnten zwei
dieser situation
offensichtlich auch im wald ausmachen
weitere 1,5 milliarden euro an
durchsucht werden wegen des verdachts
zu grabe es sind ukrainische soldaten
öffentlich bekannt aber das
zehn jahre war janine wissler dort
und wir hören bisher aus der noch
deutschen politik und der partei die
norddeutschland sonst wird das ein
berichtet haben oder sich vielleicht
schockwellen aushalten müssen nämlich
weltweiten ökonomischen probleme als der
das deutsch französische verhältnis
bisher vor allem eines aus
fraktionschefin die anschuldigungen
freundlicher und trockener tag dann aber
ist uns überlegen in einem verhältnis 10
des illegalen waffenbesitzes
verteidigungsministerium lässt heute
laufenden sitzung des beschlüsse zur
militärhilfe zukommen lassen zielinski
auch einige bisher nicht dafür
wurde besprochen und die bedeutung
die panini mit ihrer wirtschaftskrise
geheimniskrämerei transparenz sind nur
gestorben im krieg nun trauern sie an
russische finanzminister das wort
wissen dass mir keine
interessiert haben dann müssen
richten sich auch gegen ihren ehemaligen
sieben personen wurden festgenommen
wird es von südwesten deutlich
neuwahl des vorstands erst am wochenende
zu 1 bitte helfen sie uns heraus zu
hält die spd versucht nicht beleidigt zu
europas in die beiden haben sehr
und der ukraine krieg der energie und
wechselhafter ascom regenschauer und
und michelle berieten auch über
diejenigen das beantworten wir
ergreifen wollte kam es gerade eben wohl
lebensgefährten einen mitarbeiter der
ihre ziele umwelt projekte fördern und
getroffen werden sollen der
aus ungeklärter ursache geriet das haus
unterschiedliche positionen dazu gehabt
anzeigen einzelner mörder sollte ohne
bedingungen für einen beitritt der
kommen und bringen sie uns in einem
lebensmittel teurer macht geplant sind
gewitter und die breiten sich am sonntag
fraktion hier verpixelt links im bild
wirken aber fraktionschef mütze nicht
zu einer vereinbarten demonstration
fraktionsvorsitzende der linkspartei
hier sind hauptsächlich mal grau
vor allem nord stream zwei vollenden
drittstaat
in brand die polizei sieht hinweise auf
finanzprogramme auch weil man eben eine
kredite vorliegen das ist eine
ukraine zur eu sowie über den in brüssel
weiter richtung norden und osten aus
verhältnis mit einer anfangs
bartsch hatte am rande der sitzung heute
anhängern gekommen ob jemand finden der
mehrerer minister aus washington
mit den zielen transparent vorgelegt am
beklagt in einem schreiben an die partei
passiert ist bis zum abend nichts das
scheindiskussion stimmt ist dass keine
doch was genau hat die stiftung getan
globale schuldenkrise verhindern möchte
minderjährigen sexuelle nötigung in
guten abend
verbindungen zur szene der reichs bürger
gesagt dass die noch verbleibende
eingereichten fragebogen der ukraine das
deutsch spricht ist uns nicht gelungen
benjamin daniel
dass kritiker tatsachen teils
röhren gekauft maschinen geliefert
ultimatum verstrich
18 dritter landtag zusammen wichtigster
einem statement erklärt wissler ich
bedarfs- anzeigen für marder vorliegen
dass auch in deutschland die preise
als sich russland beim g20-treffen zu
einfach mal jemanden französisch wir
parteivorsitzende wissler in parteitag
die die existenz der bundesrepublik
der ukrainischen regierung gelang es
personal gestellt woher kam das geld wie
unterschlagen teils bewusst falsch
weiter stark steigen zeigen die
papier gilt als grundlage für
gucken ob das mit der besatzung bringen
weise die unterstellung ich hätte
tagesordnungspunkt einsetzung eines
deutschland leugnen er gegen sie so
im juni vorbereiten solle das klingt
wort meldet verlässt diese gruppe
bereits vor november 21 beziehungsweise
hallo liebes pas kandidat gute
darstellen sagen sie uns was bei dem
beitrittsgespräche die türkische
erzeugerpreise sie haben im märz so
heute einen flucht korridor für mario
viele millionen waren es etwas licht ins
demonstrativ den raum mit dabei unter
untersuchungsausschusses so schnell wird
zumindest nach einer wenn auch
dem jahreswechsel 21 22 kenntnis über
stark angezogen wie noch nie fast ein
treffen rausgekommen ist nein sagt
offensive gegen die verbotene kurdische
pohl auszuhandeln 90 busse sollten es
anderem die us finanzministerium die
übersichtlichen zeitlichen perspektive
schwerin und wird auch manuela schwesig
dunkel zumindest für die gründungsphase
arbeiterpartei pkk im nordirak dauert an
drittel mussten hersteller im schnitt
für diese übrig gebliebene parteispitze
saskia esken und flitzt an den kameras
vorwürfe von sexueller belästigung und
das thema nicht los
bringen diese dokumente die die
aktion zeigt unter welch schwierigen
sein am ende waren es viel weniger
mehr bezahlen als noch vergangenes jahr
wir werden weiter berichten auch bei
staatskanzlei auf öffentlichen druck
machtmissbrauch gehabt entschieden
und der linken- geschäftsführer hat
bedingungen der heutige tag stattfindet
vorbei die antwort der ampelkoalition
über opfer ist bislang nichts bekannt
zurück ich bin sofort tätig geworden als
angekündigt er werde vorschlagen im juni
jetzt veröffentlichen musste klar wird
unserem nächsten thema geht es um
preistreiber war wieder die energie
unterdessen für putin seinen krieg in
für den deutschen finanzminister begann
bleibt im dunkeln aber die frage von
verantwortung die will die
präsident erdogan drohte heute so
ich davon erfahren habe 14 monate ist es
die landesregierung hat die
den gesamten vorstand neu wählen zu
strom für gewerbe und industrie wurde um
der ost ukraine weiter unerbittlich wie
er mit einem pressefrühstück und vielen
herrn melnik ist bekannt sie betrifft
parteivorsitzende der linken susanne
stiftungsidee energisch vorangetrieben
lassen beides klingt danach dass man
wörtlich die köpfe der
schwer zu beantwortenden fragen zur
85 prozent teurer heizöl um 130 prozent
zeit gewinnen will um sich vielleicht zu
hennig welt so nicht mehr tragen sie
vor allem ein modell das die bundeswehr
hier in charkiw ich bin hier geboren es
doch welchen einfluss hatte nord stream
terror-organisation auch in syrien zu
zukunft der weltwirtschaft ich glaube
2 haben die russen etwa schwesig die
gern benutzt und gern vor zeigt der
sortieren denn der heutige rücktritt kam
schmiss heute hin offensichtlich so
zermalmen
wir sind in einer situation wo wochen
und erdgas sogar um 144 prozent die
frustriert wie ratlos ob der tiefen
er hoffe dass es den ort des
mir für alle überraschend selbst die
satzung diktiert sagten kritiker
partei pressestelle erfurts zeitgleich
macht er kann zwei meter fünfzig breite
dekaden trägen
natürlich ist es ganz normal dass man
krise in der ihre partei steckt ein
hauptquartiers der pkk bald nicht mehr
preise bei den herstellern gehen durch
gräben und hindernisse bis zu ein meter
wenn man einen solchen infrastruktur
mit uns medien die linkspartei das war
geben werde seit montag attackiert die
miserables ergebnis bei der
wir werden in ganz anderem
höhe überwinden gewässer von 1 meter 50
projekt arbeitet dann auch mit dem
die decke mit zeitverzögerung kommt dass
bundestagswahl
ja auch mal ein großes anti projekt des
zerstritten bei vielen themen unter
auch beim endverbraucher an entspannung
geopolitischen und makroökonomischen
tiefe durchfahren und besitzt eine
unternehmen spricht und vor allem auf
einstigen spd granden oskar lafontaine
anderem beim umgang mit russland und
die interessen des landes schaut es ging
ist erst mal nicht im sich in sicht im
steigfähigkeit von 60 prozent 380 marder
umfeldern den nächsten jahren arbeiten
dann noch ein sexismus skandal im
um arbeitsplätze unternehmen es ging
jetzt riecht das irgendwie nach sichtung
gegenteil viele volkswirte glauben ende
hessischen landesverband der allerdings
da scheint eine partei geradezu in
eher die ko vorsitzende janine wissler
abwicklung kann sie das noch stoppen
berührte auch ihr schicksal steht jetzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]